with Grandmaster Irina Crush Irina you
picked it up where you left it last year
with dominant Victory how do you feel
right now yeah I feel pretty good about
this game I feel like you know I got a
playable position from the opening
something that I was at least interested
by and
um and probably the most interesting
moment was when I've sacked the pawn or
at least I you know I offered that E3
Pawn up and that was at uh which move
yeah it's coming up shortly yes right
here oh yeah so when I was playing
Bishop B1 yeah so I was like you know
the whole theme of this position is kind
of Peace Improvement right so my Bishop
on D2 is not the best I moved him to E1
to have you know the idea of Bishop H4
and and I was thinking you know yeah
black plays Knight C5 of course I can
play Bishop F2 or I can play Bishop B4
um but ultimately yeah I thought well
you know the Knight went there to take
my Bishop I don't really like to give up
Bishops you know
um so Bishop B1 seemed like a reasonable
Pawn sack because E3 Pawn is weak and um
as long as my king is on H1 I don't
really mind losing it all my pieces get
to be on really good squares I would say
like in this position you know the Rook
on eight is still not in the game the
knights on C5 a bit awkward bishop and
D7 is restricted so I just thought like
well this is did you feel like you have
enough speed for your attack right now I
I thought this this is what is called
compensation in chess right like if this
is a compensation that I don't know what
it is yeah and you play Bishop to H4
Rook to E5 and by the way she was
spending a lot of time did that play
into your consideration to give up the
pawn just because she was getting no no
I think that's that was really just my
chest understanding give up Pawn I would
have done that pretty much in any
scenario but certainly it made things
harder for her to defend you know a
position where white has the initiative
and and then you have no time and
honestly I never saw anything like very
convincing for black I mean okay it was
not my job to solve all of Black's
problems but really I didn't see
something you know I mean I felt like
she her um her attempts were not quite
gonna do it but I didn't know what was
going to save black in this position yep
and that's exactly what happened all of
your pieces were just swarming around
hurricane and this pin was so difficult
to get oh yeah
you know I have a video on my YouTube
channel that I recently started called
pins are dangerous so I guess you know
um yeah this will be example number two
excellent excellent Knight to D7 Knight
to F5 and after that you just broke
through and you finished yeah I noticed
there was going to be a little check
here actually I'll just show at the end
if she takes my queen uh the key point
is that there's Bishop C5 check and then
I was still trying to evaluate this
position because I was like well rook
cd1 and then Pawn D4 opening the bishop
with rookie two ideas and here I was
just thinking you know maybe just Bishop
D3 just like don't mess around and don't
let rookie two happen and eventually
okay the dark squared Bishop should
that's be decisive probably the smart
decision in this position Arena there's
something about the American copy it
just feels like you were coming with
extra motivation but also a lot of
confidence do you feel that way as well
well you know it's interesting it's only
the second time around it's hard to say
um but I mean I feel good about this
tournament I'm happy to be here I'm
always happy to be in St Louis
um and I do like this format it's a very
unique format I don't get to play
anything else like that that's kind of
match uh format I mean the only other
thing is like a world championship
knockout something like that that I've
played in before but that's the that's
kind of um maybe it doesn't give you any
second chances like this one does
um although I'll try not to not to need
Second Chances you know as much as
possible and um yeah it's happy to be
here and that's exactly what you did
last year congratulations we'll see you
tomorrow thank you Christian
absolutely thank you Irina
congratulations indeed just